[Musik]
sebastian lee gestreckt frischkäse mit
billigen zutaten
er lüftet das filadelfia geheimnis und
zeigt was wirklich im frühstücks
klassiker steckt
[Musik]
peter goerke
milka
intense wow das ist alles philadelphia
und das witzige ist wendig philadelphia
ausspreche wissen sie sofort was gemeint
ist so ähnlich wie bei pampers sie war
oder tempo taschentücher und dahinter
steckt einer der ältesten tricks
überhaupt die geschichte von
philadelphia beginnt im jahr
1872 in new york wo william lorenz den
angeblich ersten frischkäse der usa
herstellt zum erfolg wird dieser erst
als er ihn unter dem markennamen
philadelphia auf den markt bringt ein
genialer schachzug die gleichnamige
stadt in den usa galt damals als
inbegriff von sauberkeit und qualität da
war geradezu himmlisch
so sahen ziemlich
philadelphia
morgens hört sich das echt gut an
frisches brot frisch käse marmelade
drauf ist ja lecker ich mag das auch und
gibt es in allen geschmacksrichtungen
kräuter süß salzig wahnsinn aber was
steckt drin in deutschlands beliebtestem
frischkäse sebastian lege schaut genauer
hin und macht eine erstaunliche
entdeckung
das ist gar kein frischkäse
[Musik]
das ist eine frische zubereitung und
wenn man den machen möchte geht es los
mit frischkäse ja es geht damit los aber
es wird mich damit auf denn bei einer
frischkäse zubereitung wird die
hauptzutat der frischkäse möglichst
unauffällig und günstig gestreckt mulke
entschied bei der käseherstellung also
die milch kommt den großen bottich david
lab zugegeben enzym aus gegen die milch
gerinnt und das aus übrig bleibt ist die
molke damals war das viel futter heute
peter streck stoff maike besteht zu 90
prozent aus wasser sie ist billig und
darum bei vielen herstellern beliebt
damit sich die marke mit dem frischkäse
und etwas weil es zu einer homogenen
masse verbindet setzt man will es auf
zusatzstoffe
verdickungsmittel damit sich auch die
wolke überhaupt nicht mehr absetzen kann
die würde sonst wieder nach oben steigen
bei der frischkäse sehr sehr komprimiert
und sehr fest ist
verdickungsmittel macht die michael fest
und den frischkäse cremig in
philadelphia steckt johannesburg ermin
wenn ich jetzt hier auf den knopf drücke
dann ist aus dem frischkäse eine
frischkäse zubereitung geworden mehr als
100 jahre alt ist dieses erfolgsrezept
und es funktioniert besser denn je trotz
corona konnte model s seine gewinne im
vergangenen jahr sogar steigern auf 3,8
milliarden euro auch dank philadelphia
jetzt wird kasse gemacht ja zum wohl
nochmal gut umrühren und
er wohl und fertig ist die frische
zubereitung
das hier darf nicht mehr frischkäse
genannt werden
und wie cremig wahnsinn haben auch kurz
probieren
philadelphia
war und hier
wahnsinn da ist soviel molke drin und
immer noch so cremig war nicht cremig
dank bindemittel und billiger molke ein
cleverer trick den sich philadelphia gut
bezahlen lassen
echter marken frischkäse von buckow oder
exquisa kostet etwa 70 cent pro 100
gramm philadelphia ist am teuersten und
kostet fast dreimal so viel wie echter
um gestreckter frischkäse vom discounter
frischkäse ist wirklich ein sehr
ursprüngliches lebensmittel wir haben
milch wir haben ein bisschen
zitronensäure und dann ist das produkt
eigentlich schon wird zum frischkäse in
einen zubereitung wie philadelphia
dürfen noch andere zutaten die sorgen
dafür dass ich in diesem produkt noch
ordentlich wasser ein speichern kann das
heißt ich kann weniger produkt für mehr
geld verkaufen weil einfach viel wasser
enthalten ist verbrauchern schmeckte
seit jahrzehnten in immer neuen
geschmacksrichtungen
die aktuelle variante philadelphia -
ganz neu und mit noch mehr profit für
man will es und jetzt kommt es das
gleiche produkt als mus wie wollen sie
doch luftig locker leicht beim produkt
der doppel haben stufe mehr luft
besseres gewissen und wie bekomme ich
jetzt da luft rein
[Musik]
seine maschine aller lege
wir haben aus frischkäse eine frische
zubereitung gemacht mit molke stärke
bindemittel und jetzt eine luftig
lockere mousse und auf der zutatenliste
steht mit stickstoff aufgeschlagen
und das mache ich hier mit komplett
befüllt stickstoff drin
achtung entdeckung gehen mit hochdruck
press der produktentwickler stickstoff
in die frischkäse zubereitung das
resultat erinnert in der konsistenz an
schlagsahne
[Musik]
apa ap
volumen noch bei meinem schnell
verdoppelt weil durch stickstoff
entsteht ja auch volumen die bläschen
sind stabilisiert und das ist ja normal
und das andere ist die mus in der mund
steckt außer stärke noch gelatine und
auch dieses rezept ist ausgesprochen
profitabel im vergleich zum ohnehin
schon teuren standard philadelphia ist
so eine muss nämlich noch einmal 25
prozent teurer
es geht nicht nur um die rezeptur um den
inhalt es geht sehr stark auch um die
emotionalität was er mit einem kauf von
marken und deren produkte verbinden und
diese ebenso lied führt dazu dass wir
bereit sind mehr zu bezahlen die konzern
ist ein gigant der lebensmittelindustrie
was wissen verbraucher über mobiles
sebastian lege fragt nach
dirk und denis h
kennt ihr die firma wandel ist man
gelesen wir die kennen irgendwann mal
gehört glaubt bei mirakel vips ende
hinten drauf also jetzt vom namen her
nicht überhaupt nicht jetzt enthüllt
sebastian lege welche marken zu mandl es
gehören da zeigt sich die beliebten
produkte hatte fast jeder schon mal im
einkaufswagen
thematisch
das wusste nicht
toblerone und milka schokolade
philadelphia druck cracker und mikado
essstäbchen das alles und noch viel mehr
stammt von bombay hättest du gedacht
dass das alles produkte von ein und
derselben firma sind ich bin ich bin
verwundert wusstest du dass ich wieder
was anderes
ich würde fast sagen wir hatten von all
den produkten hatten wir schon
mindestens 50 prozent mal gekauft tja ja
auf jeden fall aber hätte gedacht dass
ein konzern ist er diese ganzen produkte
herstellt habe ich darüber nachgedacht
und das ist nur ein auszug aus dessen
produktpalette sowie vielmehr der marken
trick lässt model s weiter wachsen heute
ist der konzern in rund 160 ländern
aktiv mandl es entstand 2012 in den usa
bei einer abspaltung von kraft foods
mit mehr als 26 milliarden dollar
jahresumsatz ist mandl es heute eine der
größten
lebensmittelkonzerne der welt
[Musik]
hey und wenn euch unsere videos gefallen
und ihr nicht genug kriegen könnt von
unserem besser ist dann gibt es hier
noch mehr videos und las amazon
abonnieren -button da ich würde mich
freuen bis bald